entre los retos que debe enfrentar el
nuevo gobierno paraguayo está la crisis
climática las intensas sequías así como
las fuertes inundaciones hacen que su
economía aprenda de un hilo y que el
crecimiento suba y baje dependiendo de
las inclemencias del clima la
exportación de soya representa el
27,8% del total exportado por el país en
2021 mientras la exportación de carne
bovina fue del 14,5% en 2012-2019 y 2020
hubo una calidad del pib debido al
fenómeno meteorológico en 2022 una nueva
sequía azotó al país y la cosecha de
soya cayó afectando los ingresos del
país el cambio climático se convierte en
un gran desafío para un país cuya
economía está ligada de forma intrínseca
a la producción del campo la comisión
económica para América Latina y el
Caribe cepal advirtió que hacia el año
2100 si el aumento de las temperaturas
del planeta
continúan Paraguay podría perder el 2%
del producto interno bruto el documento
también advierte que la agricultura
familiar Es decir de los pequeños
agricultores se vería afectada por una
falta de recursos para enfrentar las
consecuencias materiales del cambio
climático global además se prevén
repercusiones en la fauna y la flora con
algunas especies que podrían extinguirse
también la salud de los paraguayos se
vería afectada ya que las enfermedades
ocasionadas por el dengue o infecciones
respiratorias aumentarían de forma
significativa para intentar combatir la
inminencia del calentamiento global
desde 2022 se lleva a cabo un plan de
adaptación al cambio climático promovido
por el Ministerio del ambiente y
desarrollo sostenible este tipo de
política será particularmente necesaria
no solo para este gobierno sino para los
próximos Rosa